>> Neil: ALL RIGHT.
YOU'RE PROBABLY WONDERING WHAT
NEW COULD BE HAPPENING AT THE
BORDER?
DISTURBING DEVELOPMENTS.
BILL MELUGIN AT EAGLE PASS WITH
MORE.
HI, BILL.
>> GOOD AFTERNOON TO YOU.
BELIEVE IT OR NOT, TODAY WAS ONE
OF THE BUSIEST DAYS WE'VE SEEN
IN RECENT MEMORY IN EAGLE PASS.
WE HAD TWO ENORMOUS GROUPS CROSS
AT THE SAME TIME.
LET'S GET TO THE VIDEO.
TAKE A LOOK AT THIS DRONE
FOOTAGE SHOT BY OUR FLIGHT TEAM
IN EAGLE PASS.
THIS IS A SINGLE ENORMOUS GROUP
OF SEVEN HUNDRED MIGRANTS
CROSSING ILLEGALLY INTO
NORMANDY, A LITTLE TOWN ON THE
OUTSKIRTS OF EAGLE PASS.
THEY'RE STRETCH OUT ALMOST AS
FAR AS THE EYE CAN SEE.
SINGLE ADULTS GOING TO A
PROCESSING AREA.
WE SAW SEVERAL OF THESE MIGRANTS
ON THEIR SMART PHONES FACE
TIMING PEOPLE AS THEY CROSSED
ILLEGALLY IN TO THE TEXAS AREA.
TAKE A LOOK AT THIS VIDEO OUR
DRONE TEAM SHOT AS THE GROUP
REALLY STARTED TO GATHER AROUND
AND WAIT FOR PROCESSING.
IT WAS A GROUP OF OVER 300
MIGRANTS.
I HAD A CHANCE TO TALK WITH THEM
AS THEY CAME IN.
MANY SAID THEY WERE FROM CUBA,
NICARAGUA AND THE
DOMINICAN REPUBLIC.
SOME CUBANS SAID THEY PLAN TO GO
TO MIAMI TO LINK UP WITH FAMILY.
THE COUNTRIES I JUST MENTIONED
ARE NOT SUBJECT TO TITLE 42.
BEING EXPELLED TO MEXICO, A LOT
OF THESE PEOPLE WILL BE RELEASED
INTO THE UNITED STATES AFTER
DOPE BEING PROCESSED.
THERE'S NO BORDER PATROL BUSES
ON SCENE.
THERE WAS AN EVEN BIGGER GROUP
BEING PROCESSED AROUND TOWN AND
BORDER PATROL RESOURCES WERE
OVER THERE.
TAKE A LOOK AT THIS VIDEO WE
SHOT AT THE SAME TIME AS THAT
NORMANDY GROUP WAS BEING
PROCESSED.
THIS WAS ACROSS TOWN IN EAGLE
PASS.
WHAT WAS LEFT OF A BIGGER GROUP
OF 400 MIGRANTS THAT CROSSED AT
THE SAME TIME.
AS YOU CAN SEE, A MAJORITY OF
THEM SINGLE ADUL MEN.
SOURCES TELL US A 48-YEAR-OLD
CUBAN WOMAN ACTUALLY WENT INTO
CARDIAC ARREST AND COLLAPSED
AFTER CROSSING.
SHE DIED ON THE SCENE RIGHT
THERE.
THESE HUGE GROUPS THAT YOU SEE
ARE A MASSIVE STRAIN ON BOARD
RESOURCES.
WE SAW SOME MIGRANTS WALKING
DOWN A LOCAL HIGHWAY WITH NO
BORDER PATROL TO BE SEEN.
AGAIN, AGENTS CAN'T BE
EVERYWHERE WHEN THE HUGE GROUPS
ARE COMING ACROSS.
WHEN WE TALK ABOUT THE LARGE
GROUPS, BORDER PATROL DEFINES
THEM AS 100 OR MORE MIGRANTS.
LISTEN TO THIS STAT.
JUST SINCE OCTOBER 1, JUST HERE
IN THIS DEL RIO SECTOR, BORDER
PATROL SAYS THAT THEY HAVE
ENCOUNTERED MORE THAN 50 OF
THESE LARGE GROUPS HERE IN THIS
SECTOR.
AGAIN, ONE SECTOR, ONE MONTH
HAPPENING MULTIPLE TIMES